[موسيقى]
تجاوز المنتخب الفلسطيني الظروف التي يعيش
في ظلها وسط الحرب الاسرائيليه الدائره
حاليا على قطاع غزه والتي خلفت اكثر من 26
الف قتيل وهاهو ينتظر ظهوره التاريخي
الاول في الدوري 16 في بطوله اسيا لمواجهه
صاحب الضيافه منتخب قطر في استاد البيت
كلنا بنعرف الظروف اللي بتعيشها فلسطين
احنا نيش بدون دوري من 7 اكتوبر فقدر انهم
يعملوا انجاز كبير في ظل الوضع اللي
بتعيشه غزه اليوم بنتمنى ان شاء الله
يوصلوا لاكثر في البطوله هاي ان شاء الله
عننا مباراه مفصليه بينا وبين منتخب قطر
زي ما بيحكوا لا خاسر بين الاشقاء فان شاء
الله بالتوفيق للمنتخبين منتخبنا ومنتخب
قطر ولم ينسى قائد المنتخب الفلسطيني
السابق التفكير في المرحله التي تلي كاس
اسيا وهي التصفيات الم لنهائيات كاس
العالم
2026 والتي ستقام في الولايات المتحده
والمكسيك وكندا كل الدول اليوم العربيه
بترحب فينا وبرحب في منتخبنا ما في حد
بقصر مع المنتخب انه يشتغلوا لقدام يعني
ما بيقدر اليوم نكمل اللي هو معسكرات في
الب في البلد الفلسطين بظل الوضع اللي
بتعيش اليوم فلسطين يمكن كل المدن اغلاق
على جميع المدن الفلسطينيه من الحواجز
وصعب التنقلات في البلد ان شاء الله نشوف
خطه مناسبه لنقدر نكمل التصفيات في تصفيات
المونديال المقبل خاضت فلسطين مباراتين
ضمن مجموعه التاسعه وتعادلت مع لبنان دون
اهداف وخسرت استراليا بهدف وستواجه
بنجلاديش في مارس المقبل ولكن الاهم حاليا
بالنسبه لكتيبه المدرب التونسي مكرم دبوب
وال المواصله على النهج التصاعدي نفسه بعد
تجاوز دوري المجموعات والقتال للاستمرار
في البطوله على حد تعبيره بدر الزيره
جزيره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الدوحه